viens mon Dieu je vais peut-être l'air
d'un sac là mais dans ces cas là
j'utilise les moyens toutes les femmes
je vous ferai pas de petits dessins
qui porte la culotte à cette délicate
question des réponses différentes c'est
moi qui c'est mon mari et moi qui
commande donc enfin
c'est nous deux
ensemble c'est moi
tous les deux
quand il y a une grande décision à
prendre on en discute à deux et on
décide à deux c'est tous les deux tous
les deux en principe c'est mon mari et
la vieille école et c'est tous les deux
c'est tous les deux ensemble je crois
qui commande le mari automatiquement
vous aimeriez que ça change ah non
absolument pas il y a des heures bien
souvent mais je pense que il est
prépondérant que ce soit le mari qui est
l'autorité pour beaucoup de choses il y
a plus de poids je pense que ça dépend
des caractères mais je pense que la
femme en principe doit compter sur
quelqu'un de plus fort
[Musique]
de la famille qu'est-ce qui commande
dans ta maison
quand tu veux quelque chose toi à qui tu
t'adresses
la plupart du temps c'est à maman
pourquoi tu t'adresses à ton papa alors
c'est pour le soir quand je l'ai pas le
droit de regarder la télé je lui demande
si je peux rester
et en général qu'est-ce qui te dit je
veux rester des fois quand il y a pas
l'école est-ce qu'il arrive que papa
disait oui tu peux et que maman dise non
tu ne peux pas avec les enfants c'est
moi qui décide
pour tout
pour la religion pour l'éducation pour
les vacances pour les études je suis
tout moi je vous dis je j'ai toujours
mené là-bas j'avais deux enfants c'est
moi qui les ai élevés
très bien
vous auriez préféré qui s'occupe un peu
plus ah oui il y a le domaine de l'homme
qui réservé à l'homme puis le domaine de
la femme qui est typiquement toujours
femme l'autorité c'est important ah oui
moi je pense que c'est important mais
enfin on est à deux et je crois que
c'est partagé de toute manière il y a
pas l'autorité du père ou de la mère les
deux peuvent apporter quelque chose à
des moments différents je suis pas du
tout d'accord pour qu'une femme commande
à la maison
non quand même le mari qui a
qui doit faire preuve d'autorité
des stages
est quand même plus fort que la femme
c'est vu que c'est lui qui doit quand
même montrer son autorité la protéger la
c'est très idéaliste peut-être que
Gilles enfin c'est je trouve que c'est
comme ça que pensez-vous des femmes qui
portent la culotte ah non je suis pas
d'accord de toute façon pour moi la
femme elle sera physiologiquement
toujours dépendante de l'homme
la femme est
enfin est plus faible que l'homme elle
sera toujours dépendante d'un homme sur
un certain plan non je pense que c'est
une question d'intelligence il y a pas
de piédestal quand on s'aime on demande
la vie de chacun je trouve que c'est pas
normal une femme doit rester féminine
d'après moi prophète non qu'il ait
choisi
sur les vêtements que je porte
de le trader de force moi mon frère je
m'habille pour lui plaire parce que il
est assez difficile et il n'aime pas que
je porte n'importe quoi les vêtements je
lui demande conseil aussi c'est pour ça
qu'en définitif il prime vous voyez ce
que je veux dire je décide aussi mais
son avis prime définitif
vous avez acheté une robe par exemple
elle ne lui plaît pas la portez-vous
quand même et bien je la porte pour
faire mon ménage voilà
non c'est je commande pas disons que je
prends des décisions avec l'accord de ma
femme tout simplement
pour les invités en général oui c'est
toujours moi qui disons qu'il choisit
nos relations
à la télévision qui décide de la chaîne
à je laisse la priorité à mon mari en
principe ah moi
toujours moi quand il y en a un match
c'est il a la priorité le reste c'est
moi ma femme la regarde jamais parce
qu'elle a trop de travail c'est toujours
moi qui est dans le fauteuil est-ce vous
pensez que vous êtes plus libre que le
laisser votre mère à certainement
vous avez l'impression que les femmes
qui travaillent ont plus d'autorité à la
maison
non pas spécialement je crois que c'est
assez difficile mon Dieu lorsqu'on est à
deux à travailler dans le même ménage
les femmes d'abord ont beaucoup plus
liberté que dans le temps et en
attendant un peu à ruer un peu plus dans
les brancards lorsqu'on a une
indépendance matérielle je crois que
c'est très difficile d'équilibrer
lorsqu'on est lorsqu'on est deux c'est
déjà assez difficile d'équilibrer est-ce
que vous croyez que vous êtes plus libre
que votre mère l’était sûrement oh je
trouve que c'est mieux maintenant que la
femme a plus de droit que n'avait dans
le temps moi je parle de liberté au
point de vue tant ça j'en ai
certainement moins que maman en avait ma
liberté de choix décision là peut-être
d'accord comment vous y prenez vous
quand vous voulez faire changer d'avis
votre mari
par la douceur
non on se boude un petit peu mais ça
dure pas ah non je suis tout à fait tout
à fait contre la bouderie je trouve que
c'est ridicule et on perd du temps je
préfère me soulager un bon coup ça va
mieux oh je lui donne une raison tout le
temps parce que pour avoir la paix je
préfère j'essaie de faire un petit peu
de charme quand ça me plaît pas mais on
fait il est charmant tout se passe
toujours bien j'ai beaucoup de chance
mais je suis pas mariée depuis longtemps
c'est peut-être pour ça aussi je parle
je parle je parle je parle j'explique
n'est-ce pas je montre ce qui serait
bien dans quelques fois je suis obligé
d'abandonner j'abandonne et j'abandonne
facilement ça dépend des moments des
fois je le prends par la douceur et
d'autres fois à l'usure à force
d'insister
viens mon Dieu je vais peut-être l'air
d'un sac là mais dans ces cas là
j'utilise les moyens toutes les femmes
je vous ferai pas de petits dessins
ce jour-là on se fait les yeux on se met
les gars on fait la chatte
et j'apprends à la fille à faire la
château de
alors il dit si vous y mettre toutes les
deux je suis fichue voilà tu trouves ça
normal que ce soit la femme qui commande
dans un ménage ou le mari oh ben je
trouve ça ça dépend quoi je trouve que
ça doit être ça devrait être les deux
quoi parce qu'il y a aucune raison que
la femme soit inférieure à l'homme et
l'homme inférieur à la femme quand il
sera grand qu'est-ce qu'il commandera
chez toi
ça dépend quelle femme je
[Musique]